lockdown measures are strictly enforced
all the places that are empty now Arenas
Schools public places streets police
were called after some customers started
fighting over toilet paper and water we
slashed red tape to develop vaccines and
therapies as fast as it can possibly be
done drugs that were developed
originally for HIV and for the flu their
anecdotes of them being used and people
getting better and the virus is clearing
very quickly we must look out for each
other we must pull each other through
this because if there's one thing that
is more contagious than this virus it is
love and compassion
I don't have to say anything we all know
these are unprecedented times
since the first report of covid-19 in
Wuhan China it has spread all over the
globe
as China grappled with the crisis the
world watched it seemed distant to most
but then slowly and surely a wave of
infections began to appear in your city
governments Health officials and the
public scrambled to make sense of the
situation and drastic changes were made
for many the ceasing of everyday life
has become a surreal shock not
experienced since the Second World War
it's a difficult time for most as
confusion and uncertainty prevail
there's certainly been chaos but also
hope
in this episode we'll be covering some
of the tools that are being used to
battle the disease scientists and
doctors around the world are using the
internet to publish information faster
than ever before this has yielded some
potential Solutions while we wait for a
vaccine that could be over a year away
treatments with existing drugs have
shown to be working in very early trials
this special episode will include a chat
I had with Dr Gerald Evans an infectious
disease specialist from Canada we'll get
to the solutions a bit later but first
we must understand the enemy
[Music]
covid-19 otherwise known as the
coronavirus is an infectious disease
caused by the SARS Cove 2 virus
it's around 10 to 34 times more fatal
than the flu though it's hard to know
exactly how many people have milder
cases so the true fatality rate may be
lower
[Music]
incubation period of the virus has been
reported to be around 2 to 14 days with
a median of five to six days
one case study suggests that the
incubation period could extend out to 24
days although this hasn't been verified
widely but this long incubation period
is what makes this disease dangerous
you can be infected for quite a while
and not feel sick while unknowingly
passing it to others this phenomena is
known as asymptomatic transmission
a joint study by seven researchers found
that over 80 percent of the people in
Wuhan weren't recorded and most of them
weren't showing severe symptoms
speaking of which what are the symptoms
of this illness
well according to one study the most
common symptom is a fever at 87 of
people experiencing that and then a dry
cough at 67 and next fatigue at 38
percent
but interestingly there's some new data
suggesting that a loss of smell may be
an early indicator
Studies have shown that the virus can
live on surfaces anywhere from a few
hours to a couple of days depending on
the surface material
as you've all heard this is why you
should practice frequent and thorough
hand washing and also avoid touching
your mouth nose and eyes where the virus
can enter
so why does washing your hands work well
the virus has a fatty layer on its
outside which breaks down with soap
destroying its effectiveness
so something that's not really talked
about is how exactly this virus kills
people it's a bit Grim but it's
important information
although covid-19 can damage the kidneys
heart and male reproductive organs
covid-19 kills by the development of
acute respiratory distress syndrome or
ards for short
it all starts with our lungs
think of it like this if the main part
of our lungs are a tree trunk in
branches our alveoli are the leaves
they're the little tiny sacs on the end
of our lungs that extract oxygen from
our blood
human lungs have about 600 million
alveoli
ards is worse than pneumonia because
with pneumonia it's only a local
inflammation whereas ards inflames all
of the alveoli across the entire lung
the inflammation of the alveoli stops
oxygen from getting into them and to
make things worse they fill up with
liquid
the consequence is that you can't
breathe and without intervention you
could suffocate to stop this a patient
with ards will need ventilation until
the swelling goes down
in some cases this can take upwards of
two weeks remember this detail this is
why hospitals are quickly running out of
space it's because people that need
intensive care and need assistance
breathing can stay in there for a long
time and this is why it's so important
to stop the spread of this disease
let's talk about that
[Music]
slowly getting across now but until
recently many people were still
dismissive about this
to them this was just the flu and a big
fuss over nothing but they didn't
understand the problem
the first part of the problem lies in
mathematics it seems that people don't
understand exponentials admittedly
they're unintuitive to us humans
a good example popularized by Chris
Martinson is as follows
imagine a baseball stadium
if you started with a drop of water that
doubles every two seconds guess how long
it would take to fill up
few days a couple of weeks
here not even close
it would take 50 minutes to fill up
even more unintuitively at 45 minutes
the stadium would be 93 empty
in other words 93 of the stadium is
filled up in the last five minutes
this is essentially the same law that
the virus follows
essentially an exponential growth
pattern
for example one person in facts two and
two people in fact four and four people
in fact eight
Etc and by the time you know it the
numbers have exploded
to put that into perspective to what's
happening now the first 100 000 cases
took 90 days the second hundred thousand
cases took 12 days the third hundred
thousand cases took four days
so to explain why this is happening we
need to discuss something called an R
naught Factor
this represents on average how many
people a single person can infect a
value above one means the virus will
spread and Below one means the virus
will die out
but the thing is the r naught Valley is
not intrinsic to the virus it depends on
environmental conditions and the
behavior of a culture or Society
according to multiple epidemiology teams
this novel coronavirus is said to have
an R naught between 1.4 and 5.5
so one person could spread it to more
than five people but we have the power
to change this value for example in
South Korea extreme amounts of testing
allowed for the locations of the virus
to be known so people and their contacts
could be isolated the greatly reduce the
spread of the disease and so far they've
got it under control
fastening the curve it was first
trending on Twitter a few weeks ago and
then soon every government official was
saying it and now I'm sure we've all
heard of it
it's the practice of social distancing
otherwise known as physical distancing
to slow the rate of spread so that
Hospital Systems don't become
overwhelmed with those who are most at
risk
at first most people thought it was the
elderly and those with underlying health
conditions but later data is starting to
show that younger people are starting to
end up in trouble
and nobody seems to know exactly why
just yet
for some practical examples here's the
difference between two cities in Italy
Bergamo and Lodi
Lodi had the first case of covid-19 in
all of Italy and implemented a shutdown
on February 23rd while Bergamo waited
until March 8th
we also have some hard data from the
Spanish Flu of 1918. here's the
difference between mitigation and no
mitigation in two different cities
Philadelphia and St Louis
so most countries were too late to
implement South Korea's policy but
flattening the curve does work
but there is one major problem with it
it intrinsically kills economies and
this is why a lot of governments were
very slow to adopt the measure
some of you may have heard of this but
it's a pretty interesting anecdote
one lady who became known as patient 31
defied calls to get tested and instead
went to a buffet and two packed turret
Services where she ended up infecting
over a thousand people
according to the Career Center for
Disease and Control prevention she may
single-handedly have caused 80 percent
of the virus cases in South Korea so
that's an example of what not to do and
why it's important to keep social
interactions to a minimum
okay so now that we're familiar with the
virus let's move on to some good news
let's discuss some of the emerging
treatments that are coming out now
so for right now a vaccine is out of the
question most experts think that's at
least a year away so why so slow
will vaccines have to go through many
stages before they're deemed safe I'll
give you one example to highlight why
this takes time
back in the 2000s scientists were trying
to make a SARS vaccine in animals
the vaccine elicited an immune response
and produced antibodies like it was
supposed to so that seemed good but upon
reinfection the immune system of the
subject animals went into overdrive and
killed the animal
so we really don't want to rush
something out like that to the entire
human population
said phase one trials have started in
Seattle and are set to start in other
places around the world because of these
desperate war-like conditions scientists
are skipping past the animal trials and
going straight to human subjects this is
very risky but the scientists conclude
that it's necessary
while we wait for a vaccine a treatment
is needed for infected patients or even
as a preventative measure to stop people
from getting ill in the first place
I'm not going to go through all of them
here but just for your information
there's at least 35 possible treatments
that are showing promise
if you're interested in reading more
about them I'll leave a link below
however out of all of these there's one
that's standing above the rest
hydroxychloroquine it comes in another
form called chloroquine and we'll be
talking about both here these drugs are
interesting not just because of their
potential but also because of the
controversy surrounding them
from being hailed as a cure for the
coronavirus to being blamed for the
death of a 60 year old man who took
covid-19 treatment into his own hands
it's a bizarre story but let's try and
cut through the noise and figure out
what's going on here
goroquin has a long history during the
1600s in Peru the indigenous people were
extracted the bark from the sinch on a
plant they used this bark to fight
chills and fever
in 1934 chloroquine was first identified
in Western science and used for malaria
since then it's had a wide range of uses
anything from HIV treatment to
autoimmune diseases
according to landsat infectious diseases
there aren't any significant detrimental
side effects but recently this has come
under debate and we'll talk about this
later
so how does it work
the following information is from Dr C
Hill of medcram
so here's a cell in your body
and this is a virus
inside of it is some RNA replication
instructions drawn in green
the viruses like to attach to something
called an ace2 receptor which is found
in large amounts inside of our lungs
once the virus attaches itself it
releases its RNA into our cells
sadly our cells internal Machinery read
the RNA which gives us instructions to
produce more of the virus RNA
the coronavirus has basically hijacked
ourselves to make more of itself once
the replication is complete the new
viruses detach themselves and go off to
infect more cells repeating the process
so what can be done
well it turns out that zinc and iron
form disrupts this replication process
so if everyone just takes zinc tablets
we'll be fine right
well wrong
zinc basically has zero intracellular
penetration when consumed
in other words zinc ions can't get into
a cell by themselves in order to do that
they need something called an ionos4
essentially an ionis 4 is a key that
unlocks the door for zinc to get through
into the cell
in addition to changing the pH levels in
such a way that stops the virus from
bonding chloroquine is an ionus form and
this is where things get interesting
early studies for covid-19 treatment are
showing promising science
a French study conducted tests on 36
patients
20 were treated with a drug and 16 were
a control group after six days a hundred
percent of the 20 patients tested
negative this number was less than 20
for the control group
although encouraging this study has been
criticized for its design and Dr Evans
also says not so fast
the the issue with other things like
hydroxychloroquine the use of an HIV
drug called kalitra or pinovir retinovir
it's a mixture and even the use of an
antibiotic called azithromycin that's a
little bit more tough to decide whether
or not we're actually seeing a good
signal of Effectiveness and the reason
for that is that most of those have been
in open label use in other words a
physician's just decided I got nothing
to lose here I'm just going to give it
to the patient and maybe that patient
would have improved anyways so we really
need trials that look at comparators of
similar patients who did get it and
didn't get it and I guess I am
optimistically hopeful that
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine which
is a relatively
cheap generic drug that at least you
know if we can gather enough data they
may work and who's the right person to
use it in and when should we use it and
those are big unanswered questions that
we may not really have the answers to
until this has really gone into its
later phase but I'm cautiously
optimistic how's that I probably should
have started prevented me all these
other words from Ohio despite this
everyone from China to Norway Australia
France and the United States and many
other countries are employing
chloroquine or at Cypher cousin
hydroxychloroquine
hydroxychloroquine has been shown to be
40 less toxic in animal studies in late
March the Indian national task force
instructed doctors to take
hydroxychloroquine as a preventative
measure against covert 19. so how did we
get here how did scientists pick
chloroquine a decade's old drug as a
candidate to battle covet 19.
as far back as 2005 experiments on cells
showed a 90 reduction in the SARS
coronavirus when treated with
chloroquine though this study was
limited as the drug was only added five
hours after infection though the
interesting part was that chloroquine
showed 100 prevention of the SARS virus
with just 10 micrograms meaning that it
may even prevent the SARS coronavirus in
the first place
the conclusion of the study basically
was this is extremely effective but we
need more studies in animals
reason being the results of experiments
and cells may not translate 100 in
living flesh
fast forward 15 years and a Chinese
study on the 4th of February 2020 found
an 100 destruction of covid-19 with just
10 micrograms
again this was done in cell culture and
not in humans nevertheless the study
concluded quote chloroquine is a cheap
and safe drug that has been used for
more than 70 years therefore it is
potentially clinically applicable
against the 2019 encoff
around the same time in early February
chloroquine phosphate was selected from
tens of thousands of existing drugs to
fight covid-19 by Chinese scientists A
Press Conference was held to announce
this
on February 17th Chinese scientists ran
a trial of 100 patients in 10 hospitals
They concluded that the drug should be
included in the Official Guidelines of
covert 19.
at this time while the world was
battling the crisis word of the Chinese
studies started reverberating around the
world
since South Korea would also issue
guidelines including chloroquine as an
effective treatment
on March 10 2020 Raymond James and
Associates wrote a piece titled if a
covid-19 therapy doesn't benefit a stock
does it even exist and in the piece you
can hear the frustration of medical
researchers
quote you may not have read much about
chloroquine yet since it doesn't benefit
any stocks if we had to pick a treatment
at this point that actually seems most
likely to have the biggest impact on
treating covid-19 in the coming years
and months it would be chloroquine they
go on chloroquine shouldn't be left out
of the discussion of covid-19 therapies
and may actually be leading the pack
restingly the pattern for chloroquine
expired long ago so now it's a generic
drug meaning that there's no money to be
made
on March 17th a trial of the medication
began in 50 hospitals in Queensland
Australia
as of March 23rd over 20 more hospitals
across Australia have asked to use
hydroxychloroquine in studies with over
2 400 patients
what we're doing is we're going to look
at 2400 Australians and rigorously study
these drugs and see what happens but you
suspect it's the magic of the
combination do you that's what we
suspect how confident are you that these
drugs will work you know my guess
is that this is probably going to be
about 80 percent there eighty percent
chance of success
on the 18th of March the news Outlet
axios reported that the drug company
Bayer will supply chloroquine to the US
government for potential use if approved
so all of this was looking bright for
the drug until March the 20th
[Music]
on the 20th of March in a press
conference Donald Trump had announced
that the FDA had approved chloroquine
for the fight against covert 19. it is
known as a malaria drug and it's been
around for a long time and it's very
powerful the drug chlorakine has been
used to treat malaria since 1944. early
testing in the U.S show its effective at
preventing and treating severe acute
respiratory syndrome or SARS a close
cousin to covert 19. just minutes later
the FDA came out and said that this
wasn't the case however the drug would
be fast-tracked and looked at harder for
a potential treatment a lot of red tape
would be cut
after this something strange happened
though after the announcement people
rushed out and bought and hoarded the
medication presumably to use it to
protect themselves against covert 19.
this took the drug away from those who
actually needed it for their health
hoarding the medication is truly unfair
to those who need it it's the selfish
action that could leave vulnerable
people stranded and seriously at risk
news outlets like Bloomberg and the New
York Times ran reports saying that Trump
mentioning the drug as a possible Game
Changer was irresponsible
people came out of the woodwork saying
that the drugs were dangerous and could
cause a mass number of deaths
this was all happening while I was
researching it was bizarre to see the
script flip so quickly in real time
a French Professor who ran a clinical
trial using the drug against covid-19
expressed his shock at how these
commonly used drugs were suddenly being
labeled as poison at just the precise
point where the world needs themselves
the main reason for the negative
sentiment is that people are going to
take hydroxychloroquine without
professional medical guidance and this
is indeed dangerous
on March 23rd a 60-year-old man consumed
fish tank cleaner with chloroquine as an
active ingredient the formula was
different to the medical version of the
drug and the man ended up dying not only
this but if you have a heart condition
chloroquine can actually be fatal as it
causes heart irregularities
to add to this blindness is a rare but
known side effect of long-term use there
are also negative interactions with
existing medications which have to be
looked at the studies mentioned earlier
screened for these risks and excluded
candidates that would have a bad
reaction
of the anecdotes I've read most mention
no side effects but some do complain of
nausea and even peeling of the skin
looking at the official common side
effects most of them seem to be pretty
mild but it's the rare reactions that
are concerning and it shouldn't have to
be said but in no way should you take a
drug like this without medical guidance
[Music]
fight these extraordinary events some
doctors are already prescribing
hydroxychloroquine to infected patients
after assessing the risks and it is just
tentatively showing to be effective now
joining us via Zoom is Dr Jeff Collier
he's the former governor of Kansas and a
practicing physician who wrote an
eye-opening op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal advocating the use of
hydroxychloroquine in two ways to treat
patients and has a prophylaxis to
protect healthcare workers from
infection we looked at the data we
looked at hearing what was going on
around the world and after the test tube
confirmation we found there's a French
study and then also a Chinese study and
several anecdotal reports that this is
an effective drug and frankly it's our
only option what we want to do is we are
treating those patients who have tested
positive we are also treating their
immediate family members that they are
quarantined in with as well the second
group that we're looking at is for
providers who have a serious exposure
the EMT who intubated somebody in the
field making sure that they get a course
of this medication also though people
seem to have a better outcome when given
early uh to them and that is the bottom
line here there is some hope anecdotally
it tentatively seems to be working but
we should still be cautious in our
optimism
well he uh he was basically on a death
door for the first couple days in the
ICU
um they gave him a very low survival
chance and uh about two days into his
stay in the ICU they put him on the
medicine and he's taken a significant
turn for the better and looks like he's
gonna make it oh thank goodness
there's a direct correlation of me
taking it and me feeling better 10 hours
later 52 year old Rio jardinieri says
the reason he's still alive is because
hydroxychloroquine an old anti-malaria
medicine it started out with the with
the fever and the headache and then
progressed to heavy sweating and then I
got developed a very bad pain and like
doctors put him on oxygen in the ICU but
he says he was still unable to breathe
after more than a week in isolation with
it getting harder to breathe he said his
goodbyes to his wife and three children
certain people in the world you can't
check out without saying goodbye to
uh and no matter who you are no matter
what scenario you're in you're never
prepared then a friend sent him a recent
article about hydroxychloroquine it has
already proven successful to treat
coronavirus patients overseas though it
hasn't been approved by Health officials
after some back and forth with an
infectious disease doctor he was
authorized to take the drug basically
with no symptoms
it was pretty crazy I looked I woke up
looked directly at the clock and it
dawned on me wait a minute I can breathe
my wife says what's wrong with you I
said what do you mean she goes you sound
normal
you know so that was a sure song I had
something had gone right he since had no
fever or pain feels fine and he's able
to breathe again I'm 100 convinced this
is what saved my life although it's not
completely settled and there is some
controversy over it many researchers do
think that it could turn the tide in the
battle against the virus
but fundamentally we'll just have to
wait for the results of these studies to
make sure
like Dr Gerald Evans said maybe these
people might have gotten better anyway
it could be possible that the
chloroquins are just a big red herring
but I really hope that's not the case
I'm going to be so interested in seeing
the results of further studies here's
former FDA commissioner Dr Scott
Gottlieb on the issue the
hydroxychloroquine the president keeps
saying there's a good chance that it
could have a great impact can you
separate fact from fiction well look it
is being used that this drug was being
used off label by doctors around the
country prior to it sort of becoming the
subject of a lot of discussion at a
national level the data this is both in
vitro data meaning and test tubes as
well as clinical data coming out of
China and also a study out of France
it's very preliminary and it's a very
small number of patients
um certainly something that we should
follow up on and they're going to be
proper clinical trials underway
it must also be noted that this kind of
treatment can't be used on patients who
are too far advanced in their illness
this is because by the time they're in
serious trouble the virus has pretty
much left the system at this point
leaving the body to fight it off and at
this point antivirals aren't going to
work
out on the heels of the chloroquins is
another drug showing promise it's a
Japanese flu drug called favipiravirum
it works through the same ionosphere
mechanisms as chloroquine a Chinese
clinical study of 340 patients showed 91
improved versus 62 percent of the
control group
the head of China's Science and
Technology Ministry stated quote it has
a high degree of safety and is clearly
effective in treatment end quote
a Chinese study in late March showed the
possibility of using the blood of the
recovered to treat the sick in the study
five critically ill patients were given
antivirals and were in ICU the doctors
gave them blood plasma that contained
antibodies of covid-19 survivors the
results
ards resolved in 12 days and three
patients were released from hospital
while the other two were stable
so that doctors don't have to go around
finding survivors and taking their blood
it's proposed that the cells that
actually make the antibodies can be
cloned and then be used to produce a
mass treatment again this is hopeful but
these are early days and we have to wait
for more studies
along with the over 30 other treatments
that are being looked at there's a good
chance that we could have some options
to fight covid-19 in the coming months
so there is a reason to have some
tentative hope
although this is a hard time it's
important to know that progress is being
made some of the smartest minds are
pulling together also in this whole
situation there's been a remarkable side
effect that I've seen a shared sense of
adversity has done something interesting
it's brought people together Community
is starting to come back after its
erosion in the past 30 years I've seen
strangers on Facebook offering to help
the elderly get their groceries I've
seen groups come together to help nurses
and check on their mental health yes
some people were Panic buying and
fighting in stores but these other
groups of people are showing that we can
rise above
this tough time could make us realize
what's important in life loving each
other family and helping each other and
that's encouraging to see
so that's about it but I have to give a
very important shout out to the nurses
and the doctors who are working hard on
the front lines and all of this with
very little direction from their
respective governments
you guys are the literal Heroes the
soldiers on the front lines
thank you for the amazing work that
you're doing
and lastly to everyone out there we're
going to get through this
scientists and researchers across the
globe are fighting this it's a
collaborative effort not seen since the
second world war and the best news of
all I've seen Vlogs from people living
in China and they're starting to emerge
from This Disaster it's early proof that
this eventually will end
the meantime please stay safe
in Good Humor I'll leave you with a few
gems from Italy's quarantine we all
Gotta Laugh right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yeah
if you're bored at home and just want to
see some more cool stuff I have hundreds
of videos on my channel that you can
binge
in the next episode we'll see how
technology is helping the covid-19
battle from drones delivering medicine
to robots autonomously disinfecting
hospitals with UV light artificial
intelligence is getting involved in lung
CT scans to take the load off doctors
and also to analyze your cough to
diagnose you instantly all of this and
more in the next episode of Cold Fusion
thanks for watching my name is dagogo
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll see you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys stay safe
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]